hello I'm Luca Bordeaux from Microsoft
Research Cambridge so what we what we
are working on is new experiences where
we use some machine learning
technologies and we embed them inside
tools such as Excel people love to use
Excel to to work with data and we are
trying to assist users in the whole
pipeline of acquiring data and analyzing
them so an example of the other things
you can do with these tools is this is a
sheet of expenses that i got from my
bank and the task i want to do is to
label these entries into various
categories such as food or bills or
entertainment so if i start doing that
for instance the first one would be food
and this one would be for instance over
as soon as i have two entries for this
colin the tool is trying to basically
learn what are the characteristics of
each category and to suggest the user
ways when it has enough confidence
what's the right label so for instance
all of these entries are accurately
categorized as food and if i continue
just a little bit for instance this
would be a bail so some bill entries
start appearing and if I feel one more
or let's say as entertainment we already
have a few more entry so I get quite a
few entries for each click with this
application so it's a much more
productive way of labeling data so
another example using the same machinery
in technologies with a different context
is when you want to analyze data so for
instance here we have a table of partial
data but the votes of US Senators then
we have a number of missing value so for
instance we don't have the affiliations
for a few of the setters we don't have
for instance the percentage often how
many times they follow the party vote
for a few of them and we have a number
of missing a's and nays for a number of
issues so a de story is doing here is a
slightly different experience where i
just select a range and i can press this
autocomplete button which will analyze
the data and propose values for the
missing cells so for instance we can see
that
john kerry's predicted to be rightly a
Democrat the other thing that this story
is doing is that it's also highlighting
values that stand out so for instance
here this value is highlighted as an
outlier and we are excited about this
these new experiences because we think
it's real way to democratize machine
learning machine learning currently is
really only usable by a small number of
specialists and we think that with the
right simple experience within Microsoft
products such as Excel there is really a
way to open it up to a broad range of
people